we have never met um face to face i feel
like i know mickey now are good friends
apparently she's coming up to canada to
do a hallmark movie
and so she might be in my neck of the
woods and i'll have to go see
so you recorded in this house with like
seven other guys living there and it's
stew from the reclass house
what was that like it's a party like you
show up at the front door and there's
like seven guys there
at the island they're like what's up
dean oh yeah
you want a beer you know let's go have
smoke and and yeah and so and all of
that i've got to go upstairs and like be
serious and record a song called boys
don't know what they have they think
there's always green or grass
there's always stages to recording
something right like writing something
putting down the vocals and seeing how
it all comes together but this was an
extra i guess separation wrinkle
whatever you want to call it it must
have felt a bit strange to
kind of wait for the final product right
it is because music is such a
collaborative
event like you're always working off
other people's energy and stuff and so
to be so isolated
i imagine this was the same case for
mickey too like she's saying it in her
bedroom
and so to you know to get that vibe and
to get that feeling whatever that you
want when you're collaborating
especially when you're singing
it was a challenge for sure